welcome back to New rockstars I'm Anna
vanson and we saw y'all's comments
asking for a Wally fun facts vid and as
a fan of this little robot myself I am
happy to oblige Wally was the first
Disney Pixar film added to the Criterion
Collection and was even inducted into
the U.S national film registry for its
significance it's a powerful story that
explores the meaning of humanity and
love that you absolutely shouldn't watch
while you're PMSing as I found out as I
cried for the third time while watching
anyway there are hundreds of fun facts
about Wally but here are 10 particularly
fun ones creating a main character who
the audience could empathize with
without speech was the movie's first
obstacle but writer and director Andrew
Stanton whose name you might recognize
from my 10 fun facts about Toy Story
video is the writer for that movie
definitely knew it was possible and
noted how the Pixar Luxo lamp inspired
him with how simple the design was while
effectively projecting a clear
personality then in 2003 Stan was at a
baseball game thinking about the design
of Wally when he was handed a pair of
binoculars to watch the game since they
were way back in the stands he and
actually noticed how much inherent
character these binoculars had and spent
the whole inning turning them upwards
and downwards to convey happiness and
sadness and the sheer expressiveness
that simple motion conveyed made Stanton
realize that that same design could be
used for Wally's eyes to display how he
was feeling to get a sense of how to
tell stories through a purely visual
medium Stan said that him and the team
watched every single one of Buster
Keaton and Charlie Chaplin short films
and features every day during lunch and
their characters shaped both Wally as
well as the whole movie writer Jim
Reardon said that for a long time they
struggled to figure out what Wally's
story arc would be after all usually a
hero grows or changes over the course of
their Journey but it just wasn't working
they realized Keaton and Chaplin's
characters and stories didn't really
have an arc to them and instead their
characters were purely who they were and
it was how everyone else was affected by
them that mattered that unlocked the
answer for them and they decided that
the heart of the story lied in Wally
being himself in turn teaching humans
how to be human and teaching robots how
to feel emotions this led to Eve getting
the main story arc as her love for Wally
allows her programming to be overwritten
now it was Ben bird who did the voice of
Wally as well as Mo but he did so much
more than that too after all in
animation they have to completely build
the soundscape from the ground up they
can't even get a room tone from a live
set so an animated feature that had very
little dialogue was a tall order Burt
was one of the most famous sound
designers on the scene who had created
many of the iconic sounds for the Star
Wars franchise like the hum of a
lightsaber the Blaster gun sound and
perhaps most fittingly R2D2's voice at
the time he had just come off of Star
Wars episode 3 and exhausted with sci-fi
told his wife no more robots but when
Stanton approached him with a request to
be 80 of the voices for the movie he was
intrigued by The Challenge and agreed to
the project Bert said in an interview
that he created 2 600 sound files for
Wally which dwarfed that already huge
1000 average sound files that the Star
Wars movies required and he's revealed
how some of the sounds were made to name
a few several of the rocket sounds were
made with a thunder sheet the Cockroach
Skinner was made with a clicking of
handcuffs said his neighbor who was a
policeman had he used a combination of
sounds that included an old army radio
generator and an inertia starter from an
antique biplane to create the sound of
Wally's Treads the Wasteland sound is
from a 1987 Niagara Falls trip he took
where he recorded the waterfalls from a
distance and he even ran up and down a
carpeted hallway with a heavy canvas bag
to create the howling wind effect for
the Windstorm and honestly that's where
I would have called it cardio
let's talk about the design of Earth in
2805 A.D an exact year we get from the
movie Bernie which takes place at the
same time as Wally the world design
shown in the opening of the movie
beautifully demonstrates the dystopia of
the world became before humans had to
leave it the gas prices are exorbitant
there are hundreds of gas pumps and ATMs
in a shot with a b l CEO doing the
Richard Nixon resignation hand sign
money is strewn all over the ground
showing its uselessness at the end of
the world and wind turbines are buried
under piles of trash demonstrating how
Society didn't act until it was too late
and of course there are skyscrapers made
of the trash cubes that the Wally robots
were built to make art director Anthony
Kristoff noted that stacking the trash
parallels a similar situation that his
home country of Bulgaria had he recounts
how the city of Sofia had a huge trash
issue where they didn't know where to
put the Overflow resulting in moving it
from one place to another eventually
stacking it in Bales when creating the
landscape they didn't want it to seem
disgusting or repulsive and reason that
the sticky gooey types of trash would
have been long gone since the time the
human was evacuated I said they wanted
to go for more of an organized ghost
town and the designers looked at
pictures of abandoned buildings and
factories with Kristoff saying that
Chernobyl stood out to him the most in
the way that it's one of the few places
that is so large of an area and yet
completely abandoned them leveled when
deciding how to arrange the trash in a
way that didn't completely feel like a
dump shading art director Bert Berry
said that they actually took a page out
of the book of flower arranging where
they placed the bigger shapes first and
then filled in the blank spaces with
smaller trash resulting in a more
visually appealing design visually
appealing trash also happens to be my
band name it's a solo act perhaps the
most visually appealing part of the
planet is Wally's home which is where we
get a taste of live action footage from
his tape Hello Dolly and Wally was
actually the first time Pixar ever used
live action in a full-length feature
film Lindsay Collins revealed it was
this tape that backed them into a corner
of having to demonstrate through the
plot why live action people existed in
an animated world but why Hello Dolly
Stanton had done the show in high school
and at first just enjoyed the odd
juxtaposition of the Aesthetics in the
film in Wally's World but the content of
the songs also fit the movie and he
realized that the hand holding would be
a good way to represent the meaning of
love to Wally with I love you not
realistically being in a robot's lexicon
interestingly enough the close-up of
them holding hands didn't actually exist
in the 1969 film so Pixar was permitted
to zoom in on the original film element
also interestingly Thomas Newman who did
the music for Wally had an uncle named
Lionel Newman who did the music for the
film Hello Dolly there are also tons of
Easter eggs and references packed into
Wally's home there are several real
world references like Big Mouth Billy
Bass and an Atari 2600 on which he plays
prong along with a twinkie-esque snack
cake that held a cockroach sleeps in
joke being that both twinkies and
cockroaches can last forever but some
Pixar references you can spot are a
dynaco lighter and Mike Wazowski Rex and
ham toys John ratzenberger who voiced
ham in Toy Story and is in many a Pixar
movie also voices the character John in
this movie whose name is no coincidence
some Easter eggs that appear outside are
Elite glass bottle a sponsor are from
Cars a scooter from Ratatouille the Luxo
lamp a Pizza Planet delivery truck an
Apollo capsule and an advertisement for
the Axiom the girl eating on the right
is actually Andrew Stan's daughter
heading into space as the debris clears
away from Wally when he leaves the Earth
you can see Sputnik one as well as the
sight of the American moon landing with
an outlet mall coming soon billboard
aboard the Axiom some of the robots have
cute names like PRT or per tea for The
Beautician bot and vaqm for the vacuum
bot the robot at the elevator's keyboard
only has zeros and ones as a binary gag
and all of the previous captains of the
Axiom are named after the movie's crew
members and while we're aboard let's
talk about the Axiom which in math and
logic is a statement or principle that's
accepted to be true unquestioned
symbolism the Axiom Drew inspiration
from several different venues story
artist Derek Thompson mentioned in the
movie's commentary track that he wanted
the Axiom to invoke a sort of vacancy
cruise ship feel which he was inspired
by when he went on a friend's wedding
cruise and founded surreal how it seemed
like everyone was a sort of captive
audience production designer Ralph
Eggleston also says that the world
aboard the Axiom was heavily inspired by
Tomorrowland Walt Disney's modern take
on a world on the move which
demonstrated an optimism about the
future that b l tries to sell its
customers Anthony Kristoff added that
they wanted to combine the colorful
almost retro naivete and we can do it
attitude of the 1950s and 1960s with a
modern vision of the future that didn't
Veer too far from plausibility to
achieve this they had Apple designer
Jonathan Ive come to the studio who
relayed that Apple's Philosophy for the
ultimate InDesign is a Surface that's
perfectly smooth with all its buttons
underneath the surface this translated
to life aboard the Axiom being basically
that a streamlined front with everything
happening beneath the surface and this
was also the concept when designing Eve
who Jonathan Ive co-designed I've Eve
coincidence I've never seen him in the
same room but Eve which stands for
extraterrestrial vegetation evaluator
has lots of new
teachers including powering things and
speaking multiple languages notably
German Japanese and Swahili and yes she
looks like an Apple product and apple
nods are actually strewn throughout this
movie Wally plays Hello Dolly from an
iPod his fully charged notification is
the classic boot up sound of a Macintosh
computer
and Otto's voice was done through
Macintosh Apple's text-to-speech system
at the time Steve Jobs was on Disney's
board of directors and him showing
Stanton the first version of an iPhone
before it came out withstand the idea of
technology and screens providing a
distraction for Humanity that and the
concept of Apple's design smoothing out
the hard edges for people led to the
overly cushy and distracted lives the
passengers aboard the Axiom LED in the
movie speaking of those passengers they
were actually not originally meant to be
humans at all sketch artist Noah
klocheck revealed that in the beginning
the film was far more Whimsical with a
floating palace and a bubble instead of
the Axiom ship and the residents being
aliens known as gelatins or gels that
looked like little Jello blobs there was
a king and queen with their court and
originally when they landed on Earth
there was a landing party where they
came out with even toe when it didn't
read well they decided to make them
human but not to the point they are in
the movie Eggleston realized that they
had a muscular dystrophy expert from
NASA visit and talk about the effects
that spending too much time in space
would have on one's body according to
him your skin would become sallow and
translucent your extremities would start
shrinking as well as your load-bearing
bones such as your ankles and eventually
your muscles would separate and you'd
revert into a gelatinous form and now we
both cannot know that but this is what
they base the next version of the gels
on which you can see in some of the
deleted scenes these gels would speak in
kind of a really lazy unclear version of
English but it just wasn't relatable and
the captain character was reading as
dumb instead of just needing to wake up
so to inject more of a Humanity into the
characters they eventually land on their
big baby kind of concept when making
this movie the team drew a lot of
inspiration from past Sci-Fi movies and
I mean a lot so let's do a Sci-Fi speed
round 2001 A Space Odyssey as the
captain gets up the Blue Danube plays
which is often tied to the space docking
scene
Jim Reardon said that in Subway's Auto
is like hell for kids and although how
the cockroach is named after film
producer Hal roach directing animator
Angus McLean jokes that it could easily
be a double reference to A Space Odyssey
as well Star Wars this hyper Drive
aesthetic and this shot being a
reference to the Millennium Falcon being
pulled aboard the Death Star they also
said in the movie's commentary that they
pushed for haties to be a language that
Eve spoke but unfortunately I think they
were mistaken that it actually made it
into the movie Star Trek the B L CEO
says space is the final fun tier the
off-brand Twinkie has a Star Trek font
and some of the imagery in this series
of shots is similar to the opening
credits of Star Trek Voyager aliens
Otto's laser is a part of an alien
reference Sigourney Weaver the leading
alien Supply the voice of the ship's
computer in Walmart
she was also the voice of the computer
in Futurama's episode love and rocket
and repeated what the ship's computer
just said in Galaxy Quest and although
it's niches heck a piece of metal that
flies by Wally in an explosion is a
reference to when the Cheyenne drop ship
exploded in Aliens miscellaneous the
ship landing on Earth is referred to as
a close encounters type shot and mosing
Wally is a predator reference and that
wraps up these 10 fun facts about Wally
some of your other favorite factoids
from the movie as always check your
sources and leave what other Disney
Pixar or Disney Pixar movies you want to
hear 10 fun facts about in the comments
until the next video you can follow me
on Twitter at atanavanston and follow
And subscribe to new rockstars and new
rockstars for more breakdowns of
everything you love and remember reduce
reuse recycle
[Music]
thank you